just got a quick tangent real quick
about japanese tv because i was watching
the other day
so i you know you know the whole meme
where they hear they react to everything
yeah i don't realize they react to
everything yeah
yeah yeah so so it was really like
some i think someone had died some
famous person and i didn't realize
they had a reaction camp from the
[ __ ] funeral and i'm like
and i'm sitting there and i'm thinking
like this is how uncomfortable would you
be as the host or they're like
react react to this guy's death this
guy's crying at the funeral react
and this is what's going like i was like
dude i was like am i missing like i
don't want to be rude to you know maybe
i'm missing
but i'm pretty sure there's nothing like
you know the japanese culture that is
like you should be reacting
like that's just weird i've been on
japanese tv multiple times it is corrupt
as [ __ ]
and like i i get that i get where the
reaction cam is there but i think i was
just thinking i'm like maybe you should
like just
turn it off for this one story like see
youtubers get cancelled for less
yeah because it's literally just a
corner and there's a guy that's like
well like it's just a funeral is like i
might do my laundry i'm like what the
[ __ ] what is it what is this
it's a little lot isn't it sorry i'm
going to change it no no so much of
japanese television is really
hypocritical to like the japanese
culture itself because like
we pose ourselves to be so modest right
and and like
private and all that stuff but then it's
like oh this person's crying zoom in on
their face
but then it's like when you're shooting
uh
shuzai like when you're shooting like a
interview or something outside
everything is mosaic in the background
so you can't like know anything and
without their consent or whatever it's
like there's such a hypocrisy there
yeah the whole like privacy law thing is
just
[ __ ] ridiculous like i remember oh my
god i [ __ ] remember there was one
prime example of like
it was like kind of like a panel like
this right like a host yeah panel kind
of thing
and i guess like one of them had like a
water bottle
but the entire water bottle was blurred
like
like but there was no like but there was
no logo on it
it was like the shape of the water
bottle would insist that it's like a
specific brand of water that's not
sponsoring the show
oh like the kudo tea or something like
yeah yeah yeah it's like you know how
like a lot of white water
oh yeah that's like a poker sweater
that's like a whatever
so they're so their option blur out the
entire [ __ ] bottle and i'm like
that just looks like exactly yeah i
can't figure out with japanese tv what's
go
why they're blowing some things and why
they're not because sometimes they'll
show you shots where nothing's blurred
and then the next shot
it'll be blurred yeah everything's
blurred and it like flips between
you know the and i can't figure it out
because it's not like in one shot
there's branding stuff
like there's branding there's people
like and then just completely cuts the
complete opposite
and i can't figure out why it does it
and it drives me [ __ ] insane
there there's somebody's just slacking
yeah i don't know yeah yeah they're like
dude i'm not gonna sit down and mosaic
three more scenes of this [ __ ]
dude oh my god you know and then
adding in all of the [ __ ] like
subtitles and [ __ ] as well like
i feel dude i feel bad for japanese like
tv editors
actually i did something with pokemon
last year
before the pandemic really went wild and
they had me mosaic frame by frame
every single person at a lollaport why
every single how long does that take
pikachu parade oh my gosh
every single man woman child everyone
even the staffers they had me mosaic
well why not just
like the entire screen at that point i
know and just like just cut out the
pikachu line just like walking down
like the like pikachu card will kind of
do this like how should you just done
that
thing at the end of the day but yeah it
was it was so messed up and it took
hours and i'm making it sound like i did
it my husband did it
you know i was slaving away watching my
husband do the work
i was just waiting for for him
i think we need more vlogs where people
are wearing like the cones for dogs
where you can just only see in the cone
hey guys i'm at
disneyland today just inside the code
honestly and it's like i don't know why
they do that for some scenes and they
don't do their fathers because like
there is never a moment on japanese tv
where like everything is blurred out
that looks good yeah it just looks like
[ __ ] it's like what am i looking at yeah
where is this what the [ __ ] a lot of
youtube videos look better than japanese
tv oh yeah i mean
then a lot of their shows are just send
a guy with a camera to this place and do
the thing
yeah exactly i mean they can get away
with more things right because like i
guess
if it's a big japanese company they
really really worry about that [ __ ] as
we
find out quite a lot yeah i mean there's
a lot of bureaucracy here um
but yeah i mean i don't watch too much
japanese tv i'd rather watch youtube
i don't watch japanese tv it's a great
inspiration they have like really
bizarre ideas
like there's so many cool tv shows that
they have i don't know which ones i've
spoke about in the park like
i swear to god i don't know what i've
spoke about on the podcast right i
talked about quite a few in the last one
that we
recorded didn't we did i did i mentioned
about the tv one where they basically
just like
go to random people and they're like hey
uh
we'll pay for your dinner if you take us
to your house yeah yeah
they would like go outside onsens wait
for the old guys to like finish
at the bath house at like midnight and
they would be like hey take us to your
house
what would they show at the house just
like their stuff how they live
how they live like what they do like
their story it's kind of interesting
really because normally i guess everyone
normally has
most people have some kind of
interesting story about yeah yeah yeah
why they ended up and especially i think
because when that when you're older
you've lived through a lot of things
yeah yeah yeah interesting honestly back
when i used to watch a lot of japanese
tv i got like
a lot of inspirations for my youtube
channel like literally like the reason
why i do so many like quiz based videos
i was just gonna say that those are my
favorites purely like all of those ideas
i'll fully admit were taken
straight off japanese tv i was just
watching um
last night there was like a three-hour q
summer special where it's like a quiz
god or quiz king or whatever and it's so
fun because they have all these
um all these like tokyo university
graduates or like
postdoc like candidates or whatever and
they're so brilliant like they're all
like mensa geniuses
and they know so much about everything
and like even though they can't like
let's say speak english they know more
vocabulary than me
which is like really gross they're like
oh yeah i can't speak
really you knew that in english like
it's one thing but then again it is kind
of like japanese english but still
yeah it's really impressive and it's fun
and um
the quiz like quiz shows are
really well done to this day i still i
think that's like one type of japanese
tv i still watched to this day other
quiz shows
they seem like they're willing to try
out ideas more than i think western tv
is i feel like we're
very refined in our ideas we like to
like
stick with what works and just only like
reiterate on top of it in some way
small iterations at a time and then
there's like weird shows in the uk
actually so
i mean there's witcher but it seems like
with japanese tv it's everything's
weird everything's a weird show which is
why i guess they you know a lot of this
got
exported to foreign tv channels that's
how japan got his image in the first
place